Terminator movies some are good some are
bad and some are harder to watch than a
nuclear apocalypse here's what we love
and hate about this iconic film
franchise as maligned as its reputation
may be among fans and critics Terminator
Salvation is a criminally
underappreciated entry in The Wider
Terminator franchise one of the things
that makes the 2009 film stand apart
from the rest is that it makes an effort
to break from the usual narrative
formula of the series trying to change
what a Terminator movie could be though
the film itself leaves room for
improvement salvation offers a
surprisingly refreshing installment in
the franchise especially compared to its
more contrived follow-ups let me if you
want to live after several movies
teasing an epic war for survival between
humanity and sentient machines
Terminator Salvation is actually set
during the post-apocalyptic conflict
after Skynet has Unleashed a devastating
nuclear attack rather than relying on
the standard Terminator plotline of
protagonists on the run from a
Relentless killing machine salvation is
a war Story one that finds Humanity on
the back foot instead of a prophesized
hero embracing their wartime Destiny
salvation follows a rugged Survivor as
he attempts to navigate the war-torn
world and it's all the better for it
the most obvious shortcoming of the
Terminator franchise is that there are
way too many sequels and reboots to the
first two movies these follow-ups tend
to get lost in their own failed attempts
to continue the original story often
playing with continuity in radically
different ways while noticeably
suffering from diminishing returns and
quality since 1991's Judgment Day there
have been four additional Terminator
movies none of which reached the
critical Acclaim of the first two films
the franchise reached its low point in
2015 with Terminator Genesis which holds
a paltry 26 percent critic score on
Rotten Tomatoes though 2019's Terminator
dark fate enjoyed the highest Acclaim
since Judgment Day with a 70 percent
Rotten Tomato score it was still a
financial disappointment earning just
261 million dollars at the worldwide box
office
composer Brad Fidel's theme and score
for the first two Terminator movies are
relatively simple but instantly
recognizable the 1984 original film
features a stripped-down industrial
sound driven largely by synthesizers
oscillators and ambient noise to set the
mood these minimalist sensibilities
balance the grounded 80s setting with
the futuristic Stakes at play Fidel
returned to score Judgment Day for the
sequel he maintained the iconic themes
from his previous work while upping the
ante in terms of instrumentation
specifically he introduced full
orchestration to the score allowing for
a Fuller and warmer sound in order to
take advantage of the heightened scope
and Elevate the story's quieter moments
Fidel's work on the score for the first
two movies subtly laid the musical
foundations for the entire franchise
Anna's influence has been felt across
every subsequent film
what day is it the day 12 May Thursday
what year the first few Terminator
movies take a relatively simple approach
to time travel mechanics soldiers from
the Future travel back in time to alter
the course of history by killing those
who would shape Humanity's Destiny
salvation largely shirks the time travel
component of the franchise altogether
telling a complete story set within one
relative period without anyone traveling
through the time stream this tight
approach to time travel descends into
progressively more complicated timeline
mechanics after salvation however making
these science fiction elements more
confusing and intrusive to each film's
story Genesis introduces the concepts of
temporal paradoxes and Divergent
timelines caused by tampering with the
space-time Continuum with the characters
lives affected by these drastic changes
dark fate goes one step further by
completely changing the future conflict
as a different sentient AI replaces
Skynet and successfully assassin nates
John Connor before he can save Humanity
disrupting the original timeline both of
these films take a relatively clean take
on the concept of time travel and model
it leading to a confusing and entirely
unnecessary mishmash of continuities
the first couple of Terminator movies
use pacing in a similar way with the
Terminators scouring the Greater Los
Angeles area for their intended targets
the lead characters are forced on the
run before regrouping to take on the
antagonist this premise provides a
perfect opportunity for filmmakers to
ratchet up the tension as the heroes lie
low only barely evading their cybernetic
pursuers before the big action set
pieces kick off when the movies do cut
loose for these action sequences they
deliver on this sudden cathartic release
of tension and suspense to great effect
all in all the Terminator movies are a
master class and action movie pacing
knowing just when to come up for air
before diving right back in the
Terminator franchise has always enjoyed
the occasional moment of humor employed
throughout the movies to break up
detention for the audience with the
film's following Judgment Day tend to
forget however is that the funnier
moments in the first two movies were
subtly employed so as to not detract
from The Narrative stakes and
overarching tone the questionable use of
humor is apparent as early as Terminator
3 rise of the Machines and does not
noticeably improve in its follow-ups
talk to the hand Genesis and dark fate
continue to poke fun at the characters
in increasingly awkward ways with the
latter portraying a retired T800 who
became an interior decorator though the
early movies were not without levity the
later Terminator entries sense of humor
Ventures into camp and self-parody in
ways that threaten to derail each
Storey's atmosphere
while the franchise as a whole is known
for its bombastic action the original
Terminator opts for a more grounded
intimate approach to its Thrills the
first movie is almost paced like a
slasher movie as the T800 brutally
eliminates anyone who gets in its way
the only major things differentiating
the Terminator from typical slashers is
a preference for Guns Over Knives and a
metallic endoskeleton of course these
horrific sensibilities are on full
display when the T800 breaks into
Sarah's apartment and kills her roommate
Ginger along with Ginger's boyfriend
Sarah desperately calls her apartment to
warn her friends of the threat but
they're already preoccupied in true
slasher movie fashion after their
romantic interlude the couple are
murdered by their stalker this moment
showcases just how Relentless the
Terminator can be while demonstrating
that the movie is just as terrifying as
it is exciting
I'll be back Arnold Schwarzenegger's
career was catapulted to new heights by
the Terminator and the franchise has
always maintained its connection to the
legendary Action Hero though
Schwarzenegger is a welcome sight in the
first few films the franchise goes to
ridiculous lengths to bring him back and
allow him to reprise his star-making
role by salvation it starts to feel like
the narrative needs to move Beyond
Schwarzenegger but the film series
itself has always existed in the actor's
shadow in a way that prevents it from
forging new ground salvation was
produced while Schwarzenegger was
serving as governor of California
prompting the 2009 movie to use CGI and
a body double instead the appearance
feels forced and distracts from the
movie's climax rather than adding any
sense of resonance or relevance to the
finale dark fate also shoehorns
Schwarzenegger's t-800 into the story
with the cyborg living in self-imposed
retirement for decades before emerging
to conveniently team up with Sarah late
in the film it's past time for the
tournament Nader franchise to move past
its biggest star
Judgment Day introduces the Fearsome
T-1000 a more advanced Terminator from
the post-apocalyptic future the t-1000's
unique composition allows him to
transform his body into different forms
as he stalks John and Sarah Connor a
breathtaking technical achievement in
1991 the special effects to bring the
T-1000 to life still hold up today as a
visually impressive feat James Cameron
worked closely with industrial Light and
Magic on Judgment Day with approximately
5 million dollars from the production
budget spent on visual effects this
investment more than paid off with the
liquid metal arguably standing out as
the most memorable visual effect in the
franchise
the Terminator films following Judgment
Day each have a tendency to employ
twists late in the story to surprise
their audiences and up the stakes
however these twists rarely connect with
audiences and serve more as distractions
than anything else for example
Terminator Genesis posits that an
alternate timeline version of John has
been transformed into a time-traveling
Terminator himself dark fate meanwhile
reveals that the retired T800 has
secretly been feeding Sarah information
to track down other Terminators a plot
point that makes less and less sense the
more one thinks about it still it could
always be worse in the unused original
ending for Terminator Salvation John
Connor is killed off altogether before
his face is grafted onto Marcus's who
then unceremoniously massacres the rest
of the movie's lead characters
at a time when female action
protagonists were a rare side in major
Hollywood Productions Linda Hamilton's
Sarah Connor became one of the most
recognizable Sci-Fi Action heroes in
history the Terminator sees Sarah
transform from a normal woman in a
dead-end job to a hardened fighter who
delivers the killing blow against the
t-800 this character Evolution continued
into Judgment Day and dark fate with
Sarah becoming a seasoned veteran who is
quite capable of taking down Terminators
by herself I'll be back
[Music]
Hamilton's performance is a huge part of
Sarah Connor's depiction not just as a
Survivor but as a warrior too Hamilton
made Sarah a Bonafide Action Hero
channeling her trauma into a Steely
resolve to balance this Hamilton
displays a tragic vulnerability in Sarah
too giving the franchise its most
nuanced performance by far
there are a few effective plot twists in
The Terminator franchise but some of
them were infamously spoiled for
audiences by the movie's marketing
campaigns in the beginning of Judgment
Day the t-800 is positioned as another
model sent back to assassinate John
before it saves him from the T-1000 in
the nick of time it's a thrilling twist
if you don't know it's coming but this
heroic change in direction for the T800
was spoiled in the film's trailers this
time there are two Terminator two
meanwhile salvation revolves around
Marcus discovering he's a cyborg after
he's inspected by human Freedom Fighters
during the war against the machines this
twist was similarly spoiled in the
trailers and television ads for the film
as a result audiences were aware of
Marcus's cybernetic secret long before
he discovered it for himself
armed with a whole arsenal of weaponry
and some of the most iconic catchphrases
in cinematic history Arnold
Schwarzenegger became a household name
thanks to the Terminator the 1984 film
almost totally revolves around
Schwarzenegger's performance as the
t-800 with his stoic demeanor and
chiseled physique defining the franchise
as a whole seven years after portraying
the ultimate sci-fi antagonist
Schwarzenegger's turn is a very
different T800 in Judgment Day
effectively reframed him as the heroic
face of the franchise there's a reason
why the film series keeps bringing back
Schwarzenegger to reprise his fan
favorite role even when it works to the
story's detriment decades after his
debut as the t-800 Schwarzenegger never
feels like he's phoning it in as the
futuristic killer even with lesser
material to work with in later films
the Terminator series is prone to the
worst kind of sequels ones that not only
dilute the quality of the franchise but
also actively make plot points from
previous installments Irrelevant this
unfortunate Trend begins as early as
Judgment Day with the Revelation that
Terminators have shifted their
priorities towards assassinating Jon
after failing to kill Sarah however the
subsequent set of sequels do even
further harm to the overarching story
and its Legacy for example rise of the
Machines reveals that machine-driven
Armageddon was inevitable all along
rendering Sarah and John's efforts in
the second movie totally useless dark
fate is the most egregious of all in
this regard with the movie opening with
a T800 successfully assassinating Jon
before he can fulfill his Destiny this
nullifies the struggles that Sarah
endured to survive in the preceding
films and the sequel scrambles to find
new ways to continue the story
[Music]